[موسيقى]
تذكروا ليله الخميس لما كان المسار هو
الحفر عليه وبعد ذلك انقلبت الامور وبدا
الحفر في محيط
يعني الحفره فاستغرق الامر تقريبا اكثر من
24 ساعه وتابعناها يعني بتلك الطريقه ديال
التوسعه التي تمت يعني ان قلبت الامور
وما كانتش الليله جيدا هي كانت ليله
الخميس تقريبا في الساعه الثانيه كنا
ننتظر ان يصل اليه لكن انقلبت الامور
فعشنا يعني توترا اخر ابنائي يدرسون في
جامعه في اسبانيا وما يؤكد هو كذلك اهتمام
الاسبان والطلب الاسباني هذا الموضوع
عائله ريان كانت مصدومه غير قادر على
التركيز معنا لتعطينا المعلومات هذا النوع
من القصص تختلط فيه المشاعر تختلط فيه
المعلومات تشح في بعض اللحظات المعلومات
كنا نمر بساعات طويله من البياض
والانتظار ونحن على بعد امطار يعني امطار
قليله من مكان تواجد الطفل ريان بين هذه
الجبال